Every year, about a half dozen people spend from late spring through early autumn walking the streets of New York, making a map of every crack, every depression, every protrusion, every pothole on every sidewalk of all five boroughs of the city.
每年大约有六个人从晚春到初秋走遍纽约街头，为全市五个行政区每一条人行道上的每一道裂缝、每一处凹陷、每一处凸起和每一个坑洞绘制地图。
So in this section, we have cracks, we have depression, and we have a broken curb.
所以在这个区域，我们有裂缝，有凹陷，还有一个破损的路缘石。
Ralph Gentles is looking at a crater the size of a manhole cover. He draws on a map he's carrying with a red felt pen.
拉尔夫·根特尔斯（Ralph Gentles）正盯着一个井盖大小的坑洞，他用手里的红色记号笔在地图上标注。
So that triangle would cover the fact that you have a depression there.
那个三角形标记就代表那里有一处凹陷。
So what you do is two triangles with a line in between them, another line, and then two x's with a line in between them?
所以你的做法是画两个三角形，中间画一条线，再画另一条线，然后画两个打叉的标记，中间也连一条线？
Yes, to indicate that the curb is also defective.
是的，这表示路缘石也坏了。
Under New York law, if you trip on the sidewalk and hurt yourself, you cannot sue the city unless somebody had informed the city beforehand that there was a problem with the sidewalk. If no one told authorities to fix it, there was no negligence. And so years ago, a group of attorneys simply decided to hire a map company to go out each year and chart every foot of sidewalk in New York. They turn in the maps to the city, which makes it possible for injured New Yorkers to do what nature apparently intended for them to do, which is take their city to court.
根据纽约法律，如果你在人行道上绊倒并受伤，除非有人事先通知市政部门人行道有问题，否则你无法起诉市政府。如果没有人通知当局去修理，就不存在疏忽。因此，几年前，一群律师决定雇佣一家地图公司，每年出去测绘纽约每一英尺的人行道。他们将地图提交给市政府，这使得受伤的纽约人能够做大自然显然想让他们做的事情，那就是把他们的城市告上法庭。
On this street, I would also look at the crosswalk. It's uneven, so we usually use some rectangles to suggest that.
在这条街上，我也会检查人行横道。它不平整，所以我们通常用一些矩形来表示。
It's an unusual job. Ralph says that wherever he goes now, he notices the sidewalk. We stand at the corner of 44th and Lexington. The window of a health food store there has a big sign that says "Juices in Sickness." It tells you what kind of juice you should drink for a long list of diseases-- diarrhea, hypertension, impotence, hair loss. Ralph, meanwhile, is looking at a hole in the ground where some water has collected.
这是一份不同寻常的工作。拉尔夫说，无论他现在走到哪里，都会注意到人行道。我们站在44街和列克星敦大道的拐角处。那里一家保健食品店的窗户上有一个大牌子，写着“疾病果汁”。它告诉你针对一系列疾病——腹泻、高血压、阳痿、脱发——你应该喝哪种果汁。与此同时，拉尔夫正在观察地上一个积水的小坑。
And we have these cracks here.
这里还有这些裂缝。
I'm just going to name some of the things that you're not putting on the map. There's a perfume and gift shop. There's a natural foods place. There's the passport photos place. In front of the perfume shop, there's a guy sitting on an crate trying to fix a gold watch. Not very well. None of this goes on the map.
我只想说出一些你没有标在地图上的东西。那里有一家香水礼品店，一家天然食品店，还有一家照相馆。在香水店前面，有个家伙坐在板条箱上试图修一块金表，修得不太好。这些都没被标在地图上。
No, none of it goes on the map.
不，这些都不会出现在地图上。
And this gets to the very heart of what mapmaking is all about. Creating a map means ignoring everything in the world but one thing. That one thing could be the bus routes or the air traffic control patterns. It could be the homes of Hollywood stars, or it could be the cracks in the sidewalk. Maps have meaning because they filter out all the chaos in the world and focus obsessively on one item.
这就触及了地图制作的核心。制作地图意味着忽略世界上除了某一样东西以外的一切。那一样东西可能是公交路线、空中交通管制模式，可能是好莱坞明星的住所，也可能是人行道上的裂缝。地图之所以有意义，是因为它们过滤掉了世界上所有的混乱，而痴迷地专注于某一个项目。
And this is the age of maps, though you might not normally think of it that way. Denis Wood is a cartographer in Raleigh, North Carolina.
现在是地图时代，尽管你平时可能不会这么想。丹尼斯·伍德（Denis Wood）是北卡罗来纳州罗利市的一位制图师。
Something like 99.99% of all maps that have ever been made have been made in this century.
有史以来制作的所有地图中，大约99.99%都是在本世纪制作的。
This century now?
指现在这个世纪吗？
This century that we're in right now.
就是我们现在所处的这个世纪。
What are those maps? And what proportion of them, do you think, are the maps that most of us civilians usually use, which are just road maps to get us one place to another?
这些地图是什么？你认为其中有多少比例是我们普通人通常使用的地图，也就是那些帮我们从一地去往另一地的道路地图？
But you see, I think you've missed all the maps right off the bat as soon as you go to the road map because you've forgotten about the maps you see every night on television, the maps that litter the newspapers.
但你看，我认为你一提到道路地图就漏掉了所有的地图，因为你忘记了你每天晚上在电视上看到的地图，忘记了散落在报纸上的地图。
The weather maps.
天气图。
The weather maps, the maps all over the magazines.
天气图，还有遍布杂志的地图。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Mapping. Every map is the world seen through a different lens. And today on our program, we bring you five different stories, five different ways of looking at the world, each story about somebody who is mapping the world using a different human sense.
大家好，这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台和国际公共广播电台联合播出的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天节目主题是“地图”。每一张地图都是透过不同镜头看世界。今天，我们将带来五个不同的故事，五种观察世界的方式，每个故事都是关于某人如何利用不同的人类感官来绘制世界地图。
Act One, Sight. Act Two, Hearing. Act Three, Smell. In that act, we pay a visit to Cyrano Sciences, makers of an electronic nose.
第一幕：视觉。第二幕：听觉。第三幕：嗅觉。在这一幕中，我们将访问电子鼻制造商Cyrano Sciences公司。
Act Four, Mapping the World Through Touch. And Act Five, Mapping the World Through Taste. Stay with us. You will not be disappointed.
第四幕：通过触觉绘制世界。第五幕：通过味觉绘制世界。请继续收听，你不会失望的。
Act One, Sight. Ordinary people using a map. According to cartographer Denis Wood, that is a very recent development in human evolution. Up until a few centuries ago, people went to war, built empires, sailed the seas, all without maps. We do have some ancient maps, a Babylonian map which seemed to be used by authorities for tax assessment, things like that. But early maps are relatively few, and usually exist to accomplish some specific purpose.
第一幕，视觉。普通人使用地图。根据制图师丹尼斯·伍德的说法，这是人类进化中一个非常近期的进展。直到几个世纪前，人们发动战争、建立帝国、航行大海，都没有地图。我们确实有一些古代地图，比如巴比伦的一张地图，似乎被当局用于税收评估等事务。但早期地图相对较少，通常是为了实现某种特定目的而存在。
That has changed, of course. Denis Wood brought into the studio a set of maps that he has been working on for years, maps of his own neighborhood in Raleigh, North Carolina, a neighborhood called Boylan Heights. Denis Wood begins with a regular locater map showing how the streets of Boylan Heights fit within the streets of the surrounding city.
当然，这种情况已经改变了。丹尼斯·伍德带进演播室的一套地图是他多年来一直致力于制作的，这是他自己所在的北卡罗来纳州罗利市一个叫博伊兰高地（Boylan Heights）社区的地图。丹尼斯·伍德先从一张常规的定位地图开始，展示博伊兰高地的街道如何融入周边城市的街道中。
And then there's a map of part of what would be seen if you were to look through the surface of the Earth into the neighborhood that we don't usually experience but that the sewer men and the gas men and so forth and so on expose whenever they-- so it's a map of manholes, gas lines, water lines, and sewer lines.
然后还有一张地图，展示了如果你透过地表向下看，看到的社区中通常感受不到，但管道工和煤气工等人一暴露出来就能看到的场景——所以这是一张人孔、燃气管道、供水管道和下水道管道的地图。
I'm looking at a map now that's got all of the overhead lines mapped on it, and it is a crazy star field. It's the power lines, the telephone lines, and the cable lines. And there's a hierarchy, of course. They flow into the neighborhood from outside the neighborhood. And as they move into individual homes, they break down. They shatter, so that the homes are all like the ends of little, teeny capillaries.
我现在看到的这张地图上标注了所有高空线路，那是一个疯狂的星空。那是电力线、电话线和有线电视线。当然，这有等级之分。它们从社区外流入社区，随着它们进入各个家庭，它们就会分散。它们破碎开来，以至于所有的住宅就像是一条条微小毛细血管的末端。
Which makes the neighborhood sound like a living organism.
这让这个社区听起来像一个活的有机体。
It is a living organism. It's absolutely what it is. Here's a map that shows the pools of light cast by each one of the street lamps at night. And it's black, and you have these pools of light.
它就是一个活的有机体。绝对是这样。这是另一张地图，展示了晚上每盏路灯投射的光池。背景是黑色的，而你拥有这些光池。
Keep going. What else have you got?
继续。你还有什么？
I've got a wonderful map that's every traffic sign in the neighborhood. And the traffic signs are each one of them drawn on the map. And the thing that's fascinating about this image is that the traffic signs are, of course, by and large for people who don't live in the neighborhood. So their density reveals those streets where strangers are going to move through the environment.
我有一张很棒的地图，上面有社区里所有的交通标志。每个交通标志都被画在地图上。这张图令人着迷之处在于，这些交通标志当然主要是为不住在社区里的人准备的。所以它们的密度揭示了外来者穿行该区域的路线。
And when you draw it on the map, do you represent each stop sign with a the little red stop sign and each yield sign with a little yellow triangle?
当你把它画在地图上时，你是用小红停牌代表停止标志，用小黄三角形代表让行标志吗？
Absolutely. Each one of these things has been drawn here. I have a map of the pumpkins that were on the porches at Halloween.
当然。这些东西都被画在这里了。我还有一张万圣节期间门廊上南瓜的分布图。
What's that one tell you?
那张地图能告诉你什么？
Well, that's an extremely interesting map. And I like to relate it to the map that shows the number of times each residence was mentioned in the Boylan Heights newsletter over the past 25 years.
嗯，那是一张非常有趣的地图。我喜欢把它和另一张地图联系起来，那张图显示了过去25年里博伊兰高地通讯中提到各个住宅的次数。
You've made a map of that?
你制作了那张地图？
Yeah. You take all the newsletters, and you just note every address that appears in it, whether it appears as the name of an individual in the neighborhood or as a specific address, and you just do frequencies attached to each one of the residences.
是的。你拿过所有的通讯，记下出现的每一个地址，无论它是作为社区中个人的名字还是特定的地址，你只需要统计每个住宅出现的频率。
Wow.
哇。
And the thing that struck me about that map when I first did it was that some locations-- that is to say, some dwellings-- are frequently mentioned no matter who lives in them. And I imagine that the people who are going to be movers and shakers in neighborhoods pick homes that are in important locations in the neighborhood or are architecturally significant or historically significant in the neighborhood.
我第一次制作那张地图时感到惊讶的是，有些地点——也就是说，有些住宅——无论谁住在那，都被频繁提及。我想那些在社区里活跃且有影响力的人会选择位于社区重要地段、或者具有建筑/历史意义的住宅。
Or they've just got more money, and then they buy the big place.
或者他们只是更有钱，然后买了更大的房子。
Well, believe me, money is what's behind both the pumpkin map and that map.
好吧，相信我，金钱是南瓜分布图和那张地图背后的驱动力。
Now, as you're telling me this story, I'm thinking, so where are the pumpkins? I'm trying to guess in my mind where the greatest proliferation of little orange pumpkins would be.
现在，当你讲这个故事时，我在想，南瓜在哪里？我在心里猜测哪里会有最多的小橙南瓜。
Oh, that's not how the map looks. What I did was photograph the pumpkins at the face. And then I printed them black on black, so all you see are the eyes and the mouths of the pumpkins on the black background. John Carpenter would love this image.
噢，地图不是那样看的。我所做的是拍摄南瓜的正面。然后我用黑底打印，所以你看到的只是黑色背景上南瓜的眼睛和嘴巴。约翰·卡朋特（John Carpenter）一定会喜欢这个画面。
So the map of the pumpkins is just a map where there are just little eyes and pumpkin mouths floating by the houses which have them.
所以南瓜图只是一张地图，上面有浮在屋子旁边的小南瓜眼睛和嘴巴。
But they're just floating on the black background, just as the traffic signs were floating. And the map of the traffic signs, there are just traffic signs. There's no streets or anything. On the map of the streets, there are just streets. On the map of the trees, there are just trees. And what you do as you go through these maps is you begin to build up-- even though it's never said-- you begin to build up the kind of structural knowledge that you take away as the residents of that neighborhood. So the idea that we have to have the pumpkins drawn against the street only makes sense if you don't have any other images.
但它们就像交通标志一样浮在黑色背景上。在那张交通标志图上，只有交通标志。没有街道什么的。在街道图上，只有街道。在树木图上，只有树木。当你翻阅这些地图时，你开始积累——尽管从未明说——你开始积累作为该社区居民所带走的结构性知识。所以，如果我们没有其他图像，把南瓜画在街道上才有意义。
But as soon as you have other images, you say, oh my lord, look. Look where these pumpkins are. Why, they're exactly where-- and I'm going to answer your question-- they're exactly where people are mentioned all the time in the newsletter. And as you go away to the edges of the neighborhood, where the people aren't mentioned in the newsletter, by golly, they don't have pumpkins on their porches.
但一旦你有了其他图像，你会说，噢天哪，快看。快看这些南瓜在哪儿。天哪，它们正好就在——我要回答你的问题了——它们正好就在通讯中经常被提到的人住的地方。当你走到社区边缘，那些在通讯中没被提到的人住的地方，天哪，他们的门廊上确实没有南瓜。
And are the people who are mentioned in the newsletter, do they tend to be the people in the bigger homes?
通讯中提到的人，是不是往往住在更大的房子里？
Yeah.
是的。
They do?
真的吗？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
Is it true you've also done a map of the graffiti in the neighborhood?
你是不是也画了一张社区涂鸦地图？
Oh yeah. The graffiti in the neighborhood, the things carved into the cement as it was setting in the neighborhood, patterns of leaf light on the neighborhood, that is to say the light coming through the leaves of the trees in the summertime.
噢是的。社区里的涂鸦，水泥凝固时刻在上面的东西，社区里树叶光影的图案，也就是说夏天光线透过树叶照进来的样子。
What does that tell you?
那能告诉你什么？
They are what it is to live in the neighborhood. The neighborhood is experienced as a collection of patterns of light and sound and smell and taste and communication with others.
它们就是居住在这个社区的真实体验。这个社区的体验是一系列光线、声音、气味、味道以及与他人沟通的集合。
Denis, if most maps, historically, have tended to be maps organized around some thing which had to be done or some purpose that people needed a map for, it seems to me that the maps that you're describing of your own neighborhood are about something very different.
丹尼斯，如果历史上大多数地图往往围绕着需要完成的任务或人们需要地图的目的来组织，那么在我看来，你描述的这些关于你自己社区的地图，讲的是完全不同的东西。
Yeah, they are. And they're very much involved with this sort of search that I have for a poetics of cartography.
是的，确实如此。它们很大程度上与我在探索制图诗学方面的研究有关。
Well, it's interesting. It's taking the premise of the map, which is that it's a way to describe the world, and then pointing it at things that we usually don't think of as being mappable.
很有意思。这采用了地图的前提，即它是一种描述世界的方式，然后将其指向我们通常认为不可测绘的事物。
Yeah, and I guess one of the contentions that I would make as a geographer-- also as a person-- is that there isn't anything that you can't map. There isn't anything that doesn't have some kind of spatial dimension or spatial character. And that spatial character is interesting. I live in this dream of maps. And I keep looking for the map that's going to really realize the potential of this thing.
是的，我想我作为一名地理学家——也是作为一个普通人——所持的论点之一是，没有什么东西是不能测绘的。没有什么是没有空间维度或空间特征的。这种空间特征很有趣。我生活在这个地图的梦想中。我一直在寻找那张能够真正实现这一潜力的地图。
But Denis, I understand this impulse of wanting to capture the whole world in a map, but do you have moments where you think that it actually is not within the power of a map to do that?
但丹尼斯，我理解那种想要用一张地图捕捉整个世界的冲动，但你有没有过瞬间，觉得地图其实没有能力做到这一点？
Yeah, I know it's not. [LAUGHS] I know it's not within the power of a map to do that.
是的，我知道它做不到。（笑）我知道地图没有能力做到这一点。
Because in fact, a map, it seems like what a map is, in a certain sense, is the opposite. A map gets its meaning by not giving you all the information about everything but by selecting, like, this map will be about this slice of the world, and this map will be about this.
因为事实上，在某种意义上，地图似乎恰恰相反。地图之所以有意义，正是因为它不给你关于一切的所有信息，而是通过选择，比如这张地图将关于世界的这个侧面，而那张地图将关于那个侧面。
Sure, and that's why I've produced an atlas in which I have, on one map page, just the faces of pumpkins, and another map page, all of the drawings of the street signs, because every map is selective. But I guess what I'm pushing for here is selecting subjects for cartographic display that are other than those that are typically done.
当然，这就是为什么我制作了一本图集，在其中一页地图上，只有南瓜的脸，而在另一页地图上，只有所有街道标志的绘图，因为每一张地图都是有选择性的。但我认为我在这里所推动的是，选择那些不同于传统制图主题的题材来展示。
It's almost like you're trying to write a novel--
这几乎就像你试图写一部小说——
I am.
确实是在写。
--but with pure symbols.
——但用的是纯粹的符号。
Maps.
地图。
Right, with maps.
没错，用地图。
Yeah. Why not?
是啊。为什么不呢？
Denis Wood is the author of the book The Power of Maps . If you want to see his maps of Boylan Heights, they're not published anywhere, but he's allowed us to post a few of them on the This American Life website. That address-- grab a pen-- www.thislife.org. That's "thislife," one word, no space.
丹尼斯·伍德是《地图的力量》一书的作者。如果你想看他画的博伊兰高地地图，它们没有在任何地方出版，但他允许我们在《美国生活》网站上发布几张。网址是——拿好笔——www.thislife.org。那是“thislife”，一个单词，没有空格。
Act Two, Hearing. Since every map is just a chart of one small slice of the world, most of the people in today's program tend to be people who decide to view the world through one small, specialized window. At some point, Toby Lester started to map the sounds in his world, the everyday sounds that surround us all the time, that most of us do not even bother to notice, much less analyze. Our contributing editor Jack Hitt visited him outside of Boston. And Jack put together this story.
第二幕，听觉。由于每一张地图只是世界上一个小切片的图表，当今节目中的大多数人往往是那些决定通过一个微小的、专门的窗口来看世界的人。在某个时刻，托比·莱斯特（Toby Lester）开始绘制他世界里的声音，那些我们随时随地被包围、大多数人甚至懒得去注意，更不用说分析的日常声音。我们的特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）在波士顿郊外拜访了他。杰克整理了这个故事。
What's on right now? I don't mean the radio. I mean, is your air conditioning on? Is your car engine idling? Is your refrigerator running? Just take a moment and listen. Listen to the droning around you. Map the landscape of your background noise. See if you can hear what Toby Lester heard one day a few years ago. I'll wait.
现在有什么声音？我不是指收音机。我是指，你的空调开了吗？你的车引擎在怠速吗？冰箱在运转吗？花点时间听听。听听你周围的嗡嗡声。绘制你背景噪音的景观。看看你能不能听到托比·莱斯特几年前有一天听到的声音。我等你。
I arrived in a new job at a new office. And in those sorts of situations, you're always kind of hyper-aware of everything. And it was quite a cold week, and the heater was just humming along very loudly to the point of distraction. And I started paying attention to it. And it was a very musical hum, and I found myself humming in the key that the heater was playing, essentially.
我在一个新办公室开始了新工作。在这种情况下，你总是对一切保持高度敏感。那是相当冷的一周，加热器嗡嗡作响，让人分心。我开始关注它。那是一种非常有音乐感的嗡嗡声，我发现自己正哼着加热器所演奏的音调。
Once he heard his heater, then Toby was in the unenviable position of not being able to not hear his heater. You too will have this problem shortly. But Tobey, who's an editor at the Atlantic Monthly, is a musical guy who hums at work. So he began to play with it, literally harmonizing with the heater, creating interesting intervals and chords, a kind of barely audible musical score to his life in the office.
一旦他听到了加热器的声音，托比就处于一种无法不去听加热器声音的窘境。你很快也会遇到这个问题。但托比是《大西洋月刊》的编辑，也是个喜欢在工作中哼唱的音乐爱好者。所以他开始以此为乐，实际上是在与加热器和声，创造出有趣的音程与和弦，这成了他办公室生活里一种几乎听不见的乐谱。
And then I started to work myself back and realized that I had probably been singing in the key of my office as long as I had inhabited an office.
后来我开始回想，意识到我可能在办公室工作的这段时间里，一直都在按照办公室的调子哼唱。
Was it a good one for you? Your high notes weren't too high?
这对你来说合适吗？你的高音不会太高吗？
No, it suited me pretty well, actually. I was able to appropriately reproduce whatever mood I happened to be in. But that's when I started wondering whether it actually wasn't working the other way around. Rather than my knowing this note was there and playing a minor third or a major third, whether, in fact, there was something else playing a note on top of the heater that would, in effect, create my mood for me.
不，其实很适合我。我能够适当地重现我当时的心情。但就在那时，我开始怀疑，是不是其实是反过来的呢？与其说是我知道这个音符在那里并弹奏一个小三度或大三度，不如说，事实上是否有其他东西在加热器之上演奏着一个音符，从而有效地为我制造了某种心情。
I found myself sitting in this little office listening to the heater and staring at my computer and suddenly realizing that yes, in fact, the computer was humming as well. Not nearly as strongly, but it was indeed humming. And that brought me to bring a little pitch pipe into the office and figure out what the two notes were.
我发现自己坐在小办公室里听着加热器，盯着电脑，突然意识到，没错，事实上电脑也在嗡嗡作响。声音没有那么强烈，但它确实在嗡嗡作响。这让我带了一个小音高管到办公室，找出这两个音符是什么。
And at the same time, for some reason, I'd been thinking about why is that we seem almost universally to assume that a minor chord is sad and a major chord is happy. If a minor third just is somehow inherently sad, then if I were sitting in an office having a minor third played at me all day long, then it's indeed possible that I could be made sad by just sitting in my office, which, of course, everybody is.
同时，出于某种原因，我一直在思考为什么我们似乎几乎普遍认为小和弦是悲伤的，而大和弦是快乐的。如果一个小三度天生就是悲伤的，那么如果我整天坐在办公室里被播放着小三度，那么仅仅通过坐在办公室里让我感到悲伤确实是可能的，而这当然是每个人都会有的感觉。
You're saying that the heating system in your office and the computer hum of your machine created a certain interval.
你是说你办公室的供暖系统和你电脑的嗡嗡声创造了一个特定的音程。
Right.
没错。
Right. So can you show us on the keyboard what was the basis of that interval?
没错。那你能在键盘上向我们展示这个音程的基础是什么吗？
It was essentially-- [PLAYS KEYBOARD]
它基本上是——（弹奏键盘）
So the first note, this one-- [PLAYS KEYBOARD] --that was like the heating system. And then your computer was doing this. [PLAYS KEYBOARD]
所以第一个音符，这个——（弹奏键盘）——那是加热系统的声音。然后你的电脑在做这个。（弹奏键盘）
Yep.
是的。
So together, what you're saying is that the interval it created was this. [PLAYS KEYBOARD]
所以放在一起，你说它创造的音程是这个。（弹奏键盘）
Right. And that happens to be a major third, which happens to be what's traditionally interpreted as happy.
没错。这恰好是一个大三度，也就是传统上被解释为快乐的感觉。
So you're loving your new job, then.
所以你很喜欢你的新工作。
Well, except for the fact that I was spending a good deal of time on the phone. And the dial tone played a note above that, which was then constructing a three-note chord. [PLAYS KEYBOARD] That was the heater, that was the computer, and then that nasty little one was the telephone.
嗯，除了我大部分时间都花在电话上这一点。拨号音在那个音符之上弹奏，然后构建了一个三音和弦。（弹奏键盘）那是加热器，那是电脑，然后那个讨厌的小音符是电话。
So all together, they were-- [PLAYS KEYBOARD] Ooh.
所以合在一起，它们是——（弹奏键盘）噢。
When played against the tonic-- or foundation note-- of his heater, the telephone created an interval known as an augmented fourth. Toby began to do some research and discovered that the Catholic Church had assigned different meanings to numerous musical intervals back in the Middle Ages. And the augmented fourth was the most reviled sound of its time-- feared as the "diabolus in musica," the devil in the music.
当与他加热器的基音相对比时，电话音创造了一个被称为增四度的音程。托比开始做了一些研究，发现天主教会早在中世纪就为无数的音乐音程分配了不同的含义。而增四度是当时最令人厌恶的声音——被视为“音乐中的魔鬼”。
Toby and I were sitting in his kitchen when I was talking to him. And suddenly I was afflicted with the same keenness of hearing that Toby had been. I heard something, and felt compelled to identify it.
托比和我在他厨房里交谈时，我突然也患上了和托比一样的听觉敏锐症。我听到了一些声音，感到必须辨认它。
What is that, now that we're sitting here?
既然我们坐在这儿，那是什么声音？
That is the tonic of the kitchen, the refrigerator humming.
那是厨房的基音，冰箱的嗡嗡声。
Let's see if we can get that. Where's the motor? Oh yeah, here. Down here. [PLAYS KEYBOARD]
看看我们能不能找到那个音。电机在哪儿？噢，对，在这儿。在这儿。（弹奏键盘）
That's the note.
就是那个音。
So what note is that?
那是哪个音符？
B-flat.
降B。
So that's the tonic of your kitchen?
那是你厨房的基音？
Essentially.
基本上是。
Not long ago, Toby had come across a critic named Deryck Cooke, who had written a book updating the church's musical classifications. Rather than finding the devil in the music, Cooke assigned quite modern interpretations to each sound. One interval, for example, seemed to inspire, quote, "a spirit of anguish." Another sound was "violent longing in a context of finality." Apparently, any combination of notes conjured its own specific mood and sensation.
不久前，托比遇到了一位名叫德里克·库克（Deryck Cooke）的评论家，他写了一本书，更新了教会的音乐分类。库克没有在音乐中发现魔鬼，而是为每种声音赋予了非常现代的解读。例如，一个音程似乎激发了所谓的“苦闷的精神”。另一种声音是“终结背景下的剧烈渴望”。显然，任何音符的组合都会唤起其特定的心情和感觉。
For example, let's just do one. This refrigerator's in B-flat. So when you come in in the morning and you put a bagel in your microwave over here, what note are we adding to the tonic here?
举个例子，我们就试一个。冰箱是降B音。所以当你早上进来，把百吉饼放进那边的微波炉时，我们在基音上增加了什么音符？
Let's listen to the microwave. Even the beeping--
听听微波炉。连哔哔声都——
What was that beep, do you think?
你觉得那个哔哔声是什么？
Let's press it again and see. A C.
我们再按一次看看。一个C音。
Right. So it's a B-flat to a C just to turn on the microwave.
对。所以只是打开微波炉，就是从降B到C。
Well, and let's look at that. Let's examine that. A B-flat to a C is a major second. And Mr. Cooke refers to it as "pleasurably longing and has a context of finality."
好吧，让我们看看。让我们审视一下。从降B到C是一个大二度。库克先生称之为“令人愉悦的渴望，并具有终结的语境”。
So play that on the keyboard here. Let's hear it.
所以你在键盘上弹一下。让我们听听。
[PLAYS KEYBOARD]
（弹奏键盘）
OK, yeah, finality. There's a sort of closure to that. And so then the bagel is ready. So let's run that microwave.
好，是的，终结感。那种声音有一种归纳性。所以百吉饼准备好了。我们运行微波炉吧。
[STARTS MICROWAVE] And that hum is an F-sharp, very identifiably. So the B-flat and F-sharp. [PLAYS KEYBOARD] Not a great way to start the day, really. And let's see, what would that be? "Active anguish in the context of flux," according to Mr. Cook.
（启动微波炉）那个嗡嗡声是升F，非常可辨。所以降B和升F。（弹奏键盘）说真的，这不是开始新一天的好方法。让我们看看，那会是什么？根据库克先生的说法，是“变动背景下的活跃苦闷”。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Active anguish in a context of flux. Did Sartre write this? [LAUGHS]
变动背景下的活跃苦闷。萨特写过这个吗？（笑）
Toby's research led him to Plato, who once wrote, "When the modes of music change, the fundamental laws of the state change." It sounds preposterous at first, but might there be a connection between the low, constant humming of our industrial culture and the dissonant mood of anxiety and irresolution that seems to characterize our century?
托比的研究让他找到了柏拉图，柏拉图曾经写道：“当音乐的调式发生变化时，国家的根本法律也随之改变。”起初听起来很荒谬，但我们工业文化的低沉、持续的嗡嗡声与这个世纪似乎具有的焦虑和优柔寡断的刺耳情绪之间，是否存在某种联系？
We're the first generation of people to live in an environment in which there are lots of devices buzzing, whirring, humming at us. I'm entirely a product of it. I have no awareness of a life led without some sort of humming appliance lurking somewhere behind me.
我们是第一代生活在充满嗡嗡声、呼啸声和机器嗡嗡声环境中的人。我完全是它的产物。我无法想象没有某种嗡嗡作响的电器潜伏在身后某个地方的生活。
Of course, there must've been noises in the 16th century that were musical. If nothing else, just nature.
当然，16世纪肯定也有听起来像音乐的声音。如果什么都没有，至少有大自然的声音。
But what appliances do that I don't think other natural world things have done is provide a steady drone. It's the droning that is really novel. My guess is that people these days find themselves a lot more bored, in general, than they used to be, partly because their appliances are taking care of things for them. But the payoff is that there's this drone behind everything. And the drone is sort of a symptom of modern life. We're very acutely aware of our own boredom, and we've been eased into our boredom by all these machines.
但我觉得电器与大自然中其他东西不同的地方在于，它们提供了一种稳定的嗡嗡声。正是这种嗡嗡声非常新奇。我猜现代人普遍比过去感到更无聊，部分原因是因为电器为他们处理了琐事。但代价是每件事背后都有这种嗡嗡声。这种嗡嗡声是现代生活的某种征兆。我们对自己感到的无聊非常敏感，而所有这些机器让我们沉浸在无聊中。
So let me restate my first question. Listening to your own background noise, do you hear what Toby Lester hears? Try it again.
所以让我重申我的第一个问题。听着你自己的背景噪音，你听到了托比·莱斯特听到的声音吗？再试一次。
Now that I can't stop hearing it, I wonder if every exercise in mapping is really such a good thing. When I sat at my keyboard composing these lines, the computer hum and fan were droning a minor third at me, an interval associated with sorrow. Before Columbus's day, the old maps simply showed an arrow pointing to the mysterious West, and then the words, "there dragons be." Maybe not every terra incognita needs discovering.
现在我无法停止听到它，我怀疑每一次制图实践是否真的都是好事。当我坐在键盘前写下这些台词时，电脑的嗡嗡声和风扇声正对着我发出一阵小三度音，这是一个与悲伤相关的音程。在哥伦布时代之前，旧地图上只是简单地画着一个箭头指向神秘的西方，旁边写着“此处有龙”。也许并非每一片未知之地都需要被发现。
But, of course, this is America. We don't just explore, we profit. Any day now, I expect a house tuner to be ringing my doorbell, some failed telemarketer who'll promise to harmonize the whir of my toaster with the flush of the toilet, and thereby guarantee me an inner peace worthy of the millennium.
但是，当然，这里是美国。我们不仅仅是探索，我们还要获利。随时随地，我都在等着一个房屋调音师来按我的门铃，某个失败的电话营销员会承诺把我的烤面包机的转动声和马桶的冲水声和谐统一起来，从而保证我获得千禧年应有的内心平静。
And you could obviously select from-- like you might select from paint chips-- from a variety of different house moods, happy, sad, active anguish in a context of flux.
你可以明显地从——就像你从油漆样本中挑选一样——多种不同的房屋情绪中选择：快乐、悲伤、变动背景下的活跃苦闷。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Jack Hitt lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特住在纽黑文。
[MUSIC--"WAY OVER YONDER IN THE MINOR KEY" BY BILLY BRAGG AND WILCO]
（音乐——比利·布拉格和威尔科乐队演奏的《小调中的远方》）
Act Three, Smell. Well, traditionally, there are maps of things you can see. And sometimes, there are even maps of things that you can hear, for example, those government maps of where the jet noise is in the neighborhoods around airports. But finding somebody who has a need to understand the world-- to chart the world's objects-- through smell, this was not easy.
第三幕，嗅觉。嗯，传统上，有可见事物的地图。有时甚至有可听事物的地图，例如那些政府标注机场周边社区喷气机噪音所在地的地图。但是要找到一个需要通过嗅觉来理解世界、测绘世界物体的人，这并不容易。
And then we found Cyrano Sciences, a Pasadena company that's trying to make an electronic nose. Ms. Nancy Updike headed out to their offices. She prepared her report in the form of those "frequently asked questions" pages on the internet. Quick warning to listeners before we begin. We have no idea if these are, in fact, the questions that people most want to know about the nose. We just like the sound of it. Here then, her report.
然后我们发现了Cyrano Sciences公司，这是一家试图制造电子鼻的帕萨迪纳公司。南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）前往他们的办公室。她以互联网上常见的“常见问题解答”页面的形式准备了她的报告。在开始之前给听众一个小提醒：我们不知道这些是否真的是人们最想知道的关于鼻子的问题。我们只是喜欢那个声音。以下是她的报告。
Hello, and welcome to Frequently Asked Questions About the Electronic Nose. Does the electronic nose look like a nose?
你好，欢迎来到电子鼻常见问题解答。电子鼻看起来像个鼻子吗？
Actually, no. It looks like a tiny table. It's a green, three-by-five plastic circuit board like you'd see inside a computer. And it's sitting on steel legs a couple inches high. It does not go on your face, needless to say. Sitting on top of the circuit board, there's something that looks like a black stamp. It's a microprocessor, the computer that runs the thing. At the other end of the circuit board, there's a white box about an inch high with the name Durante printed on it in black letters. I'm not joking. It says Durante.
其实不。它看起来像一张小桌子。它是一个绿色的、三乘五英寸的塑料电路板，就像你在电脑里看到的那样。它坐落在几英寸高的钢腿上。不用说，它不用在你的脸上。电路板顶端坐着一个看起来像黑色邮票的东西。那是一个微处理器，运行该设备的电脑。在电路板的另一端，有一个一英寸高的白色盒子，上面用黑体字印着Durante的名字。我不是在开玩笑。它确实写着Durante。
And then there's a clear plastic tube, thinner than a pencil, that the nose uses to sniff. But that's just the guts of the thing. Richard Payne is the project's chief technical officer, and he showed me a mock up of what the outside of the final product, which is going to be a handheld electronic nose, might look like when they finally give it an outside.
然后有一根比铅笔还细的透明塑料管，鼻子就是用它来嗅探的。但这只是核心部分。理查德·佩恩（Richard Payne）是该项目的首席技术官，他向我展示了一个模型，展示了最终产品（即手持式电子鼻）在最终赋予外观后可能的样子。
So one would be able to push the black buttons to give it instructions as to start or stop.
所以人们能够按下黑色按钮来给它下达开始或停止的指令。
And these are black buttons that are sitting on a yellow disc, almost like-- not a dinner plate but the next size down.
这些是坐在黄色圆盘上的黑色按钮，几乎像——不是餐盘，而是小一号的那个尺寸。
It's a dessert plate.
它是点心盘。
A dessert plate. Thank you.
点心盘。谢谢。
What can the electronic nose smell, and what can't it smell?
电子鼻能闻到什么，不能闻到什么？
If the electronic nose could draw, oh, I don't know, a map, say, of its world, here's what wouldn't be in the picture-- blueberries, movie popcorn, candle wax, pretty much every smell you can think of. The electronic nose is still a baby. It has to learn each smell for the first time, just like we had to do as we grew up. It has to build up a smell archive in its computer brain that it can compare new smells to.
如果电子鼻能绘制地图的话，这就是它画中不会出现的内容——蓝莓、电影院爆米花、蜡烛油，几乎任何你能想到的味道。电子鼻还只是个婴儿。它必须第一次学习每种气味，就像我们成长过程中所做的那样。它必须在电脑大脑中建立一个气味档案，以便与新的气味进行比较。
Here's what its map would include. Here are the smells it can identify so far. And be forewarned, It is a small, sad world, frankly, for the electronic nose. In preparation for its life as an industrial workhorse, the electronic nose has been sniffing mostly nasty solvent vapors and decaying bacteria. But when scientists want to show it off, they let it identify two perfumes-- the lovely Chanel Coco and the, in my opinion, overly sweet Bal A Versailles.
这是它的地图将包含的内容。以下是它到目前为止能识别的气味。先声明一下，说实话，对于电子鼻来说，这是一个微小而悲伤的世界。为了准备作为工业苦力的生活，电子鼻主要在嗅探令人作呕的溶剂蒸汽和腐烂的细菌。但当科学家们想炫耀它时，他们会让它识别两种香水——可爱的香奈儿Coco和在我看来过于甜腻的Bal A Versailles。
We've opened up the bottle of perfume and inserted the sampling tube. The first sound you heard was clean air being drawn in to purge the sample chamber. And now it's on the draw mode when it's identifying. And it has successfully identified Chanel Coco because it was trained to identify Chanel's Coco.
我们打开了香水瓶并插入了取样管。你听到的第一个声音是清洁空气被吸入以净化取样室。现在它处于绘制模式，正在识别中。它已经成功识别出了香奈儿Coco，因为它经过训练可以识别香奈儿的Coco。
What will the electronic nose be used for?
电子鼻会被用来做什么？
By you and me? Not much. It's going to cost $2,000 to $5,000 at first. But Richard really, really wants you to have one. So they're going to spend the next five years coming up with a model just for you, the consumer, for under $10.
你和我？没多大用处。起初它的价格在2000到5000美元之间。但理查德真的非常非常希望你拥有一个。所以他们将在未来五年内想出一个只为你（消费者）准备的型号，价格在10美元以下。
Meanwhile, the electronic nose will have other assignments. Detecting landmines. Factories could put electronic noses throughout their plants to detect dangerous gases that might be leaking during the manufacturing process. Doctors could use a handheld electronic nose to diagnose pneumonia and other conditions that have distinctive smells. Smell, actually, used to be a much bigger part of medical diagnosis decades ago. Richard tells me about one nation-- not the United States--
与此同时，电子鼻会有其他任务。探测地雷。工厂可以在工厂各处放置电子鼻，以检测制造过程中可能泄漏的危险气体。医生可以使用手持式电子鼻来诊断肺炎和其他具有独特气味的疾病。事实上，在几十年前，气味曾经是医学诊断中更重要的一部分。理查德告诉我关于一个国家——不是美国——
A more neurotic nation, shall we say.
我们可以说是一个更神经质的国家。
--that wants to use the nose in an elaborate scheme to detect counterfeit money. This unnamed nation--
——想在一个复杂的计划中使用电子鼻来探测伪钞。这个未透露的国家——
Oh, it was actually the German printing office.
噢，其实是德国印钞局。
--wanted to inject a smell into their money, a smell that would be detected by "die nase elektronisch."
——想要在他们的钞票里注入一种气味，这种气味会被“die nase elektronisch”（电子鼻）检测到。
How does the electronic nose work?
电子鼻是如何工作的？
Before we get to that, let me explain how actual noses work. The inside of your nose is filled with millions of little sensors, like sponges. A smell, meanwhile, is made up of a whole bunch of different chemicals, in the form of gases, that combine to create one specific odor.
在我们进入那个话题之前，让我解释一下真正的鼻子是如何工作的。你的鼻子里充满了数百万个小传感器，就像海绵一样。同时，一种气味是由一堆不同的化学物质组成的，以气体的形式，组合起来形成一种特定的味道。
As you breathe in-- let's all breathe in-- the gases enter your nose, and each chemical is absorbed by a different sensor that's primed to respond to that type of chemical. The sensors-- the little sponges-- then send signals to the brain. And the brain combines all the data from all the different sensors and identifies their combination as a particular smell.
当你吸气时——让我们都吸气——气体进入你的鼻子，每种化学物质被不同类型的传感器吸收，这些传感器旨在响应那种类型的化学物质。传感器——那些小海绵——然后将信号发送到大脑。大脑结合来自所有不同传感器的所有数据，并将它们的组合识别为一种特定的气味。
Right. I'll repeat the question. How does the electronic nose work?
对。我再问一遍。电子鼻是如何工作的？
So the electronic nose works almost the same way. Remember how I said it looks like a little table? Underneath the table, it has a pump, like a tiny set of lungs to draw smells in through the plastic tube. The air goes up the tube into the white box named Durante, and the box holds all the sensors. Then some of the sensors swell depending on whatever chemicals are in the air being drawn in. Electrodes measure the amount of swelling, and the microcomputer acts as a brain to coordinate all the information from all the sensors and to compare the new pattern to smells its learned before.
所以电子鼻的工作方式几乎是一样的。还记得我说它看起来像一张小桌子吗？在桌子下面，它有一个泵，就像一套微小的肺，通过塑料管吸入气味。空气顺着管子进入名为Durante的白色盒子，盒子里装着所有的传感器。然后，一些传感器会根据吸入空气中的化学物质而膨胀。电极测量膨胀量，微型计算机充当大脑，协调来自所有传感器的所有信息，并将新的模式与它之前学过的气味进行比较。
How does the electronic nose compare to a dog's nose?
电子鼻与狗的鼻子相比如何？
Dogs are used at airports to detect explosives, and they're also used in detecting landmines. Maybe you've seen them in the movies. Their nose, at this point, is pretty unbeatable for mapping smells. It has 10 times as many sensors as the human nose. And human noses have 300,000 times as many sensors as the current version of the electronic nose. But the electronic nose does have one significant advantage over dogs.
狗被用于机场探测爆炸物，也被用于探测地雷。也许你在电影里见过它们。在这一点上，它们的鼻子在测绘气味方面几乎是不可战胜的。它们拥有的传感器是人鼻的10倍。而人类鼻子拥有的传感器是目前版本电子鼻的30万倍。但电子鼻确实比狗有一个显著的优势。
Dogs, they tend to have a very short attention span. They usually are good for 15 or 20 minutes, and then it's time for another dog. An they're expensive to train. And they're very good--
狗，它们的注意力持续时间往往非常短。它们通常能工作15或20分钟，然后就得换另一只狗了。而且它们训练起来很昂贵。它们非常好——
I didn't know that. You always see the dogs being so focused.
我不知道这一点。你总是看到狗表现得那么专注。
No, they stay focused for time frames on the order of 15 minutes, maybe a good one, a half an hour.
不，它们保持专注的时间跨度大约是15分钟，好的话可能半小时。
And is the electronic nose going to be as good as a dog's nose?
电子鼻会和狗的鼻子一样好吗？
It will be a long time before it's as good as a dog's nose, but it will be someday.
离像狗鼻子一样好还有很长一段时间，但总有一天会的。
Does the electronic nose have a soul?
电子鼻有灵魂吗？
A few hours into my visit at Cyrano, I found myself, inevitably, thinking about that dilemma at the heart of so many science fiction movies. At what point does a machine achieve humanness? A machine whose sense of smell consists of counting up all the chemicals in a particular odor and naming them, is that really smelling?
在我访问Cyrano的几个小时后，我不可避免地想到那个出现在许多科幻电影核心的困境。机器在什么时候达到人性？一个嗅觉由计算特定气味中所有化学物质并命名它们组成的机器，那真的是在闻吗？
Real smelling seems different. It seems human. Real smells have associations. They evoke memories and feelings. We don't just count molecules floating through the air. What we do and what we call smelling seems fundamentally different from what the electronic nose does when it smells.
真正的闻似乎不同。它似乎是人类的。真正的气味有联想。它们唤起记忆和感受。我们不只是计算在空气中漂浮的分子。我们所做的、我们称之为闻的东西，似乎与电子鼻在闻的时候所做的事情有着本质的区别。
Richard, like any good scientist of course, has no interest whatsoever in this idea. I won't play for you any of the five minutes of tape of our going back and forth about it, except to say that he ended with--
理查德，当然像任何优秀的科学家一样，对这个想法毫无兴趣。我不会为你播放我们来回讨论它的五分钟录音，除了说他最后总结为——
I'm happy I'm a person and not a computer.
我很高兴我是一个人，而不是一台电脑。
Yeah, me too. You know, at moments like this, you really need an omniscient narrator with a deep voice to come in and wrap it all up. And I have one.
是的，我也是。你知道，在这样的时刻，你真的需要一个声音深沉的全知叙述者来介入并总结一切。我就有这样一个。
Yes, there are similarities and differences between the human nose and the electronic nose. The key difference is that powerful human computer we call the brain, which lets us sift through thousands-- even millions-- of different odors as we map our world.
是的，人类鼻子和电子鼻之间既有相似之处也有不同之处。关键的区别在于我们称之为大脑的那台强大的人类计算机，它让我们在我们绘制世界地图时能够筛查成千上万、甚至数百万种不同的气味。
Well, coming up, learning to map a city using your mouth your guide. Our little radio experiment in the five senses continues. Taste and Touch are left. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
好的，接下来，学习如何用你的嘴作为向导来绘制城市地图。我们关于五种感官的小型无线电实验继续进行。剩下味觉和触觉。稍后，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, documentary producers, and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Mapping. We're bringing you five stories, five ways of mapping the world, one through each of the human senses, sight, hearing, smell, and now touch and taste.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、纪录片制片人和表演者来处理这个主题。今天的节目是“地图”。我们为你带来了五个故事，五种绘制世界地图的方式，每种方式对应一种人类感官：视觉、听觉、嗅觉，现在是触觉和味觉。
We've arrived at Act Four, Human Touch. This is a story about somebody mapping her own body using the sense of touch. Deb Monroe is a magazine writer and contributor to public radio shows like Marketplace and The Savvy Traveler . If mapping means that you're charting only one aspect of the world, there is a good side to being obsessed with one thing. And, of course, there is a darker side.
我们来到了第四幕：人类触觉。这是一个关于某人用触觉绘制自己身体地图的故事。黛布·门罗（Deb Monroe）是一位杂志撰稿人，也是《市场》和《精明旅行者》等公共广播节目的撰稿人。如果绘制地图意味着你只绘制世界的一个方面，那么痴迷于一件事有好的一面。当然，也有黑暗的一面。
This whole thing began seven years ago. I remember the day. At a park with my daughters-- babies back then-- I came across a magazine article about breast cancer. It listed the warning signs. It suddenly didn't matter that I was in a crowded public place. I had to check. So I stuck my hand under my blouse and checked for lumps. Nothing. Then I stretched out my T-shirt and peeked inside.
这一切开始于七年前。我记得那一天。在公园里和我的女儿们（当时还是婴儿）在一起时，我偶然看到了一篇关于乳腺癌的杂志文章。它列出了警示信号。突然间，我在拥挤的公共场所也无所谓了。我必须检查一下。所以我把手伸进衬衫里检查肿块。什么也没有。然后我拉开T恤，往里面偷看。
What was that? I'd never noticed it before, a sort of puckering on the pale skin of my breasts. Grabbing the kids and carting them to a phone, I called my doctor. Come in today, he said. At the office, the nurses watched the babies while the doctor examined me. He looked like he was trying hard not to roll his eyes. Stretch marks, he said. Those are stretch marks.
那是什么？我以前从未注意到，我苍白皮肤的乳房上有一种褶皱。抓住孩子们，把她们带到电话旁，我打电话给我的医生。今天过来，他说。在办公室里，护士们照顾婴儿，医生检查我。他看起来像是在努力不去翻白眼。妊娠纹，他说。那是妊娠纹。
That experience would have stopped most people from panicking and running to the doctor. Not in my case. It catapulted me straight into the world of hypochondriacs. When life gets stressful, I do five or six breast checks a day. When things get really intense, that number goes up to 30 or 40. I've pushed and prodded my flesh so hard that I've actually bruised myself. I've done self-exams at the dinner table, in the middle of a performance at the Hollywood Bowl, and I hope they're not listening right now, but in the studios of PRI's Marketplace . I can't control myself.
那种经历本会阻止大多数人恐慌并跑去看医生。但我不一样。它直接把我弹进了疑病症的世界。当生活变得有压力时，我每天要检查五六次乳房。当情况变得非常紧张时，那个数字会上升到30或40次。我用力按压自己的肌肉，甚至把自己弄伤了。我在餐桌上、在好莱坞露天剧场表演期间，做过自我检查，我希望他们现在没在听，但在PRI《市场》节目的录音室里，我也做过。我无法控制自己。
But it's not just the breast exams. My husband Jim can tell you when it all began.
但这不仅仅是乳房检查。我丈夫吉姆可以告诉你这一切是什么时候开始的。
Probably about seven years ago. Probably when we were living in Dallas and Michaela was not very old. She was really pretty young. A few months old, maybe. That's when you had your first tumor. I can't remember where it was. Was it a brain tumor? You went through so many. I think you thought you had a brain tumor.
大概是七年前吧。可能是在我们住在达拉斯的时候，那时米凯拉还不太大。她真的很小。几个月大吧。那时你有第一次肿瘤。我不记得它在哪里了。是脑瘤吗？你经历了太多次。我想你以为你有脑瘤。
And then we moved to Chicago, and then you had stomach cancer. I believe you had another brain tumor, a couple of cases of breast cancer. Quite a survivor.
然后我们搬到了芝加哥，然后你有胃癌。我想你又有了一次脑瘤，还有几次乳腺癌病例。真是个幸存者。
You have actual physical pain. That's the weird part. You're convinced that you have had a headache for three weeks. You are convinced that your stomach has been killing your for three months, and that's got to be a developing tumor somewhere between your knees and your shoulders. You've got this cancer that's eating you alive. You're convinced of that, and it's bizarre, truly. I'm sorry. It doesn't sound very sympathetic.
你有真实的身体疼痛。那是最奇怪的部分。你确信你已经头痛了三个星期。你确信你的胃痛了三个月，而且那一定是在你膝盖和肩膀之间的某个地方有一个正在发育的肿瘤。你确信这个癌症正在把你活活吃掉。你确信这一点，这很离奇，真的。抱歉。这听起来不太有同情心。
The weird thing is that I'm so afraid I might actually find something that I don't really do my breast exams correctly. My hand darts in here, there, feels around and then, relieved that there are no obvious lumps, my hand pulls away as if it's just been burned. But knowing that I did a lousy job, I must do it again, and the cycle just repeats itself.
奇怪的是，我太害怕我可能会真的发现什么，以至于我没有真正正确地进行乳房检查。我的手在这里、那里乱窜，摸索着，然后，因为没有明显的肿块而感到宽慰，我的手就像被烫伤了一样缩了回来。但知道我做得很差，我必须再做一次，循环就这样重复了。
The cycle spiraled out of control two years ago. It was a bad time in my life. The kids were worried about starting school, and my father was on the verge of a nervous breakdown as my mother continued her decline into Alzheimer's. So when a magazine offered to send me to write about a weekend getaway for stressed-out moms in the mountains two hours south of LA, I jumped at the chance.
两年前，这个循环失控了。那是我生命中糟糕的一段时期。孩子们担心开始上学，而我父亲濒临精神崩溃，因为我母亲的阿尔茨海默症继续恶化。所以当一家杂志提出让我去写一篇关于洛杉矶南部两小时车程的山区里为压力过大的妈妈们准备的周末度假报道时，我抓住了这个机会。
Well, instead of being a relaxing, pampering experience, I kept sneaking off to the bathroom to check for lumps. I went to the bathroom so many times, one lady asked if I had food poisoning. I wonder what she would've said if she could see me, hunkered down on the grimy toilet lid under the fluorescent light, stripping to the waist so I could check myself.
嗯，这并没有成为一次放松、呵护的体验，我却一直在偷偷溜进浴室检查有没有肿块。我进出浴室的次数太多，一位女士问我是不是食物中毒了。我想，如果她能看到我在日光灯下，蜷缩在肮脏的马桶盖上，脱掉上半身的衣服进行自我检查，她会说什么呢？
Fast forward to Halloween. At a friend's party filled with children and music and wine, I was walking by a bookshelf when I spotted the Merck Manual. It's filled with descriptions of diseases and their symptoms. I tried, but I couldn't resist. The book was suddenly in my hand. My friend's husband, John, sauntered up, interested. He was sure he had a brain tumor. The repeated CAT scans must've missed it, he said.
快进到万圣节。在朋友家一个充满孩子、音乐和葡萄酒的派对上，我路过书架时发现了《默克手册》。它上面写满了疾病及其症状。我试过，但我无法抵制。书突然出现在我手里。朋友的丈夫约翰走过来，很感兴趣。他确信自己有脑瘤。他说，反复的CAT扫描一定漏掉了。
We spent the next two hours pouring over the book, following the trail of little gray boxes of symptoms to their frightening conclusions. Hodgkin's disease, stomach cancer, Ebola. John's wife marched over, grabbed the book away, and pointed meaningfully at the children bobbing for apples. My husband ordered me to stop reading medical information in books and magazines.
接下来的两个小时我们都在钻研那本书，跟随那些关于症状的小灰色框，找到了令人恐惧的结论。霍奇金病、胃癌、埃博拉。约翰的妻子大步走过来，把书抢走，意义深远地指向正在为苹果抓耳挠腮的孩子们。我丈夫命令我停止阅读书籍和杂志上的医疗信息。
He forgot about the information that comes with prescription drugs. In teeny, tiny print on the skinny piece of paper that comes with birth control pills is that bit warning women over the age of 35 about the possibility of blood clots in the leg, which can shoot up through your veins and kill you. At 3:00 AM, I woke up with a leg cramp. It had to be a clot. I paged the doctor.
他忘记了处方药随附的信息。在避孕药附带的一张瘦窄纸片上，用极其细小的字印着对35岁以上女性的警告，提醒她们腿部出现血栓的可能性，血栓会穿过静脉并杀死你。凌晨3点，我被腿部痉挛惊醒。那一定是血栓。我呼叫了医生。
Well, since I ruined all the goodwill in that relationship, I had to move on. This time, I switched to a woman doctor. Turns out we had a lot of common-- both 37, third generation Mexican-American, even grew up in the same neighborhood. She asked about the stress in my life.
嗯，因为我破坏了那段关系中的所有善意，我不得不继续前进。这次，我换了一位女医生。结果我们有很多共同点——都37岁，第三代墨西哥裔美国人，甚至在同一个街区长大。她问了我生活中的压力。
Because a lot of times, women with pain in that area will have a psychological cause for it. I would say maybe 50% of the time.
因为很多时候，那个部位疼痛的女性会有心理原因。我想可能有50%的情况是这样。
50% of the time? I'm not alone?
50%的情况？我不是一个人？
No, you're not alone.
不，你不是一个人。
What's this about?
这是怎么回事？
Knowing you as I have, I think perhaps you're just nervous and anxious about the possibility of having a problem. And with everything going on your life, it's easy to focus on something else to put your anxiety into. And at one point, it was the pelvic pain. And that resolved once you knew that maybe this is what was causing it. Now it's the breast situation. And maybe once you resolve whatever is in your life that might be triggering that fear and anxiety, that will resolve itself as well.
据我所知，我想也许你只是因为可能出现问题而感到紧张和焦虑。而随着你生活中的一切，很容易专注于其他事情来把焦虑转移过去。在某个时刻，那是骨盆疼痛。一旦你知道也许这就是导致疼痛的原因，它就解决了。现在是乳房状况。也许一旦你解决了生活中可能引发这种恐惧和焦虑的事情，那个问题也会自行解决。
Ah, fear and anxiety. They are so '90s. It's all so self-absorbed. And it's this part of hypochondria-- the self-absorption-- that I hate the most. I feel enormously guilty having such thoughts when millions of people are suffering from real problems.
啊，恐惧和焦虑。它们太90年代了。这一切都太自我沉溺了。正是疑病症的这一部分——自我沉溺——是我最讨厌的。当数百万人正在忍受真正的问题时，我有这样的想法感到极其内疚。
Everything is going along fine, and then it's like, oh, I remember the syndrome. Suddenly, we're back into it again. I think you're doing fine, you seem to be doing fine, and suddenly, I catch you feeling for a lump or something. I find it a little depressing. Suddenly, it's like what I thought was sort of a normal pattern has now come to an end, and now we're going to go through this difficult time with you being distracted and sort of self-absorbed and worried. And yeah, I almost want to slap your hand like you're a two-year-old reaching for a cookie.
一切进展顺利，然后就像是，噢，我想起了那个综合症。突然间，我们又陷入其中了。我想你做得很好，你看起来很好，突然间，我发现你在摸索肿块什么的。我觉得这有点令人沮丧。突然间，我觉得原本被认为是正常的模式已经结束了，现在我们又要经历这段困难时期，你注意力不集中，有点自我沉溺和担忧。是的，我几乎想打你的手，就像你是一个伸手去拿饼干的两岁小孩一样。
The trouble is, I think, that it takes your mind away from other things that it seems to me should be more important, because they actually exist, for one thing. I mean, the tumors don't exist and I do, your other things do, that sometimes get shunted aside when you're busy obsessing about these maladies.
我认为问题在于，它让你远离了其他看起来更重要的事情，因为它们确实存在，首先。我是说，肿瘤不存在，但我存在，你的其他事情也存在，当你忙于痴迷这些疾病时，它们有时会被搁置一旁。
Would you have ever suspected when we got married that I would end up doing this?
在我们结婚时，你曾想到我会变成这样吗？
No. It's a great question. No. Not at all. You were smart, kind of fun and liked to have a good time, seemed to be very much capable of enjoying life. You were good at what you did. Now you still are good at what you do, but your enjoyment of life has to be hampered by your constantly searching for lumps and believing you have them. That definitely doesn't seem like the kind of thing the person I married would have done.
没有。这是一个好问题。没有。一点也没有。你很聪明，有点风趣，喜欢玩得开心，看起来非常能够享受生活。你很擅长你做的事情。现在你仍然擅长你做的事情，但你享受生活的能力一定受到了阻碍，因为你不断地寻找肿块并认为自己有它们。那看起来绝对不是我娶的人会做的事情。
But this is the problem. When you start mapping your own body while consumed with fear, the map's inaccurate. The picture that you get of yourself is inaccurate. It's filled with landmarks that seem huge but really don't exist. It's a road map that always sends you driving down the wrong road.
但这就是问题所在。当你带着恐惧绘制自己身体地图时，地图是不准确的。你得到的关于自己的画面是不准确的。它充满了看起来巨大但实际上并不存在的地标。这是一张总让你在错误的道路上行驶的路线图。
Deb Monroe in Los Angeles.
洛杉矶的黛布·门罗。
Act Five, Mapping the World Through Taste. Jonathan Gold's life was changed after he decided to map his city-- one part of his city-- by relying mostly on his sense of taste. His story begins in the early 1980s. He went back to where it all happened to tell the tale.
第五幕，通过味觉绘制世界。乔纳森·戈尔德（Jonathan Gold）在决定主要依靠味觉来绘制城市——他城市的一部分——地图后，生活发生了改变。他的故事始于80年代初。他回到了这一切发生的地方讲述这个故事。
This is the historic site of Mr. Coleslaw Burger, which now is a neon sign shop specializing in Hangul characters for Korean signs. Mr. Coleslaw Burger is on Pico Boulevard. And at the time, I lived on Pico Boulevard about three or four miles down over a kosher butcher shop in a Jewish-Iranian section of town. And I took a bus down Pico Boulevard every day for my job, which was an incredibly boring legal proofreading job at a downtown legal newspaper.
这是“科尔斯劳汉堡先生”（Mr. Coleslaw Burger）的历史遗址，现在是一家专门经营韩语标志的霓虹灯招牌店。科尔斯劳汉堡先生位于皮科大道（Pico Boulevard）。当时我住在皮科大道大约三四英里外，在镇上一个犹太-伊朗社区的一家洁食肉店上面。我每天乘公交车沿着皮科大道去工作，那是一份极其枯燥的法律校对工作，在市中心的一家法律报纸工作。
My goal in those days, I suppose, was to be Elliott Abrams, who was at that time the undersecretary of state under Reagan, who seemed to have the glamorous life of flying around from Latin capital to Latin capital, meddling in everybody's economies and exhorting them all to try University of Chicago-style economics.
那时我的目标，我想，是成为埃利奥特·艾布拉姆斯（Elliott Abrams），他是里根政府时期的副国务卿，他似乎过着那种在拉丁美洲各国首都之间飞来飞去、干涉每个人经济并劝说他们尝试芝加哥大学风格经济学的奢华生活。
I had some vague idea that I wanted to be a government bureaucrat. I took every civil service test that it's possible to take. I took the country civil service test and the state civil service test. I took the post office test. I took the National Security Agency test. I took a CIA test. And finally, but probably not least, I took the foreign service test. And I got a fairly high score on it. So I assumed that I was going to, at some point, join the foreign service.
我有一个模糊的想法，我想成为一名政府官僚。我参加了所有可能的公务员考试。我参加了县公务员考试和州公务员考试。我参加了邮局考试。我参加了国家安全局考试。我参加了中情局考试。最后，大概同样重要的是，我参加了外交服务考试。我考了相当高的分数。所以我认为我会在某个时候加入外交服务。
At some point during this year, my friend, Ken, took me to this place on Pico Boulevard-- Mr. Coleslaw Burger. And Mr. Coleslaw Burger wasn't much, I guess, in terms of restaurants. It wasn't the most magnificent place I'd ever been to, and it wasn't the best-smeling place I had ever been to, and sort of a surly guy behind the counter who insulted his clients and liked to be known as Mr. Coleslaw Burger himself, although his name was probably Miller.
那一年中的某个时候，我的朋友肯（Ken）带我去了皮科大道上的这个地方——科尔斯劳汉堡先生。我猜科尔斯劳汉堡先生在餐馆方面算不了什么。那不是我去过的最宏伟的地方，也不是我去过的最香的地方，柜台后面有个粗鲁的家伙，他侮辱客户，喜欢自称是科尔斯劳汉堡先生本人，尽管他的名字可能叫米勒。
And the thing that struck me about Mr. Coleslaw Burger was that here was a man who had found his mission in life. And his mission in life was to put coleslaw on hamburgers. I'm not sure if he was the very first person to put coleslaw on hamburgers, but the first person I'd ever seen. And somehow, thinking of Mr. Coleslaw Burger and thinking of the other restaurants I'd eaten at on Pico, I came up with this sort of half-baked coleslaw-inspired idea to eat at every restaurant on Pico Boulevard and to create sort of a map of the senses that would be able to get me from one end to the other.
关于科尔斯劳汉堡先生，给我印象最深的是，这里有一个找到了人生使命的人。他的人生使命是在汉堡上放凉拌卷心菜（coleslaw）。我不确定他是不是第一个在汉堡上放凉拌卷心菜的人，但他是我见过的第一个。不知何故，想到科尔斯劳汉堡先生，想到我在皮科吃过的其他餐馆，我产生了这个半生不熟的、受凉拌卷心菜启发的想法：吃遍皮科大道上的每一家餐馆，创造一种能够带我从一端走到另一端的感官地图。
The next week, as I was coming home from work and I had really nothing else planned for the evening or, realistically, the week or the rest of my life, I decided to do that. And I came up with a set of rules. I had to go to each restaurant in order. If the restaurant was closed, I could go to the next restaurant on the list, but means the next time I was out, I had to go back to the one that I had missed the first time.
下周，当我下班回家，真的没有什么其他计划，或者现实点说，这周甚至余生都没有计划时，我决定这样做。我制定了一套规则。我必须按顺序去每一家餐馆。如果餐馆关门了，我可以去名单上的下一家，但这意味着下次我出来时，我必须回到第一次错过的那一家。
If a restaurant was really bad, I could skip out after a bite or two. If a place wasn't really a restaurant but, say, a candy store that also happened to sell hot dogs, then I'd have to try the hot dog, but I wouldn't necessarily have to make it part of my meal. And as often happens with these kind of restaurants, they'd close down. So if I'd gone two miles and then a restaurant that I had gone to had closed down and opened up again, then I would have to go and eat at that restaurant before I would be able to go to the next one. Street vendors, push carts selling tacos or mangoes were optional. I usually tried to eat at them, but I didn't consider it a fault if I didn't.
如果一家餐馆真的很差，我吃上一两口就可以走人。如果一个地方不是真正的餐馆，比如一家也卖热狗的糖果店，那我就得尝尝热狗，但不一定要把它作为我餐点的一部分。正如这些餐馆经常发生的那样，它们会倒闭。所以如果我已经走了两英里，然后我去过的一家餐馆倒闭了又重新开张，那么在去下一家之前，我就得去那家餐馆吃一顿。街头小贩，推车卖玉米饼或芒果的餐点是可选的。我通常尽量去吃，但如果没去，我不认为这是错误。
I became obsessed with the idea of Pico Boulevard. Almost every ethnic group that exists in Los Angeles, you can find on Pico. There's specific blocks that are Guatemalan and Nicaraguan blocks and Salvadoran blocks. There are parts of Pico where you can drive for probably a mile without seeing a sign that isn't in Korean.
我对皮科大道的想法变得痴迷。几乎洛杉矶存在的每一个种族，你都能在皮科找到。有特定的街区是危地马拉区、尼加拉瓜区和萨尔瓦多区。在皮科有些路段，你可以开车走一英里，却看不到一个不是韩文的招牌。
There's big sections that are Mexican, and not just Mexican but some are Oaxacan, and some are so solidly aligned with Jalisco, with Guadalajara that you see the little symbol-- the goat of the Guadalajaran soccer team, which is the Chivos-- in almost every window. And it's center for a huge concentration of Persian Jews that came over here around the time the Ayatollah took power. I don't think there's another street in Los Angeles that's quite like it.
有很大的部分是墨西哥区，不仅是墨西哥区，有些是瓦哈卡区，有些与哈利斯科州（首府是瓜达拉哈拉）紧密结合，以至于你在几乎每一扇窗户上都能看到那个小标志——瓜达拉哈拉足球队的山羊标志（Chivos）。它是阿亚图拉掌权时移居此地的庞大波斯犹太人聚集中心。我不认为洛杉矶还有哪条街道像它一样。
This is the El Parian, and the thumping you hear is a man butchering goats. El Parian is probably the best place in Los Angeles to find the dish called the birria, which is sometimes translated as "ugly stuff" and in Arizona is made with beef. But in Los Angeles and in Guadalajara-- where the dish comes from-- it means goat stew.
这是El Parian，你听到的撞击声是一个人在屠宰山羊。El Parian可能是洛杉矶寻找名为“比里亚”（birria）这道菜的最佳场所，这道菜有时被翻译为“丑陋的东西”，在亚利桑那州是用牛肉做的。但在洛杉矶和瓜达拉哈拉（这道菜的产地）——它指的是山羊炖肉。
When you come to El Parian, usually people won't ask you what you want. They know what you want. There's only one reason you come here, and that's for the birria. You start off with some chips and beans, and then they bring it out-- a big plate of goat roast. Still has the crispy parts and the savory parts and some stewy parts. And they'll our over it this broth called consomme, which is essentially a very strong broth made with amplified goat drippings and lots of chile.
当你来到El Parian时，通常人们不会问你想要什么。他们知道你想要什么。你来这里只有一个原因，那就是为了比里亚。你先来点玉米片和豆子，然后他们端出来——一大盘烤山羊肉。仍然有酥脆的部分、美味的部分和一些炖的部分。他们会浇上一种名为“consomme”的肉汤，这本质上是一种由放大的山羊滴液和大量辣椒制成的非常浓郁的肉汤。
First sip of the-- oh, my. The first sip of the consomme-- the first taste that you get is the taste of salt. And then almost immediately, like a kick in the back of the throat, the chile comes in. It's a very specific feeling. And then sort of like the round, almost arc-shaped flavor of the goat, which is gamy but not too gamy, and the meat's sweetness comes through. It's a wonderful taste. It's really well balanced. Really, I like eating the goat fine. But the goat soup that you're able to scoop out from around the goat is the best part of the whole thing.
喝第一口——噢，天哪。喝第一口肉汤——你尝到的第一种味道是盐味。然后几乎立即，就像在喉咙后部踢了一脚，辣椒的味道涌入。这是一种非常特殊的感觉。然后是那种圆润的、几乎是弧形的山羊风味，它是野味但又不会太野，肉的甜味显现出来。这是一种美妙的味道。它真的非常平衡。真的，我喜欢吃山羊肉，但你可以从山羊肉周围舀出来的山羊汤是整个事情中最好的部分。
Birria may seem like a strange thing and sort of an isolated specialty, but birria's actually hugely popular in Los Angeles, especially among immigrants from Zacatecas state and from Jalisco, whose capital is Guadalajara. And there may be as many as 100 places specializing in the dish.
比里亚可能看起来像是一种奇怪的事情，是一种孤立的特色菜，但比里亚在洛杉矶实际上非常受欢迎，特别是在来自萨卡特卡斯州和哈利斯科州的移民中。可能有多达100家专门经营这道菜的地方。
This is the last remaining location of the world famous Oki Dog, the more famous branch of which used to be on Santa Monica Boulevard in West Hollywood. The original Oki was notorious because it was where everybody went after punk rock shows at the Starwood. So you'd go there at 1:00 in the morning, and there'd be a line of 300 people with mohawks and cherry-red hair and rings in their noses and Doc Martens on their feet, flying the flag, hanging out with the freaks. The famous punk rock singer, Darby Crash, who was the lead singer of The Germs, was reputed to have had his last meal at the Oki Dog just a few hours before he OD'd.
这是世界著名的Oki Dog最后剩下的地点，其更著名的分支曾经在西好莱坞的圣莫尼卡大道上。最初的Oki臭名昭著，因为它是每个人在星木（Starwood）看朋克摇滚演出后的去处。所以你会在凌晨1点去那里，排队会有300人，留着莫霍克发型，樱桃红色的头发，鼻子上戴着环，脚上穿着马丁靴，飞扬跋扈，和怪胎们混在一起。著名的朋克摇滚歌手达比·克拉什（Darby Crash），他是The Germs乐队的主唱，据说在OD前几个小时就在Oki Dog吃了最后一顿饭。
That one got closed because it was the site of about half the crime in the city of West Hollywood. The Pico Oki, though, was the one that always had the better food. Los Angeles has always been famous for its fusion food, its multicultural concoctions of things. But the same sort of thing that was happening in much fancier restaurants like Chinois and Chaya Brasserie across town, here, Oki Dog was doing almost the people's version of it.
那一家被关了，因为它是西好莱坞市大约一半犯罪现场的所在地。不过，皮科的Oki一直拥有更好的食物。洛杉矶一直以其融合食物、多种族创造的东西而闻名。但同样的事情也在城里像Chinois和Chaya Brasserie这样更高级的餐馆里发生，在这里，Oki Dog几乎是在做人们自己的版本。
My favorite item, the pastrami burrito-- which is a truly fearsome creation capable of feeding four people for four days-- is a greased bun made with fried pastrami, fried cabbage, fried peppers, a glob of chili, pickles and onions if you want them, and wrapped inside a burrito, which is to say food with influences of Chinese food, Jewish food, and the Los Angeles chili tradition, wrapped in a burrito which is Mexican style, cooked by Japanese guys for an almost exclusively African-American clientele.
我最喜欢的食物，熏牛肉玉米煎饼（pastrami burrito）——这是一种真正可怕的创造物，足以喂饱四个人四天——是一种用炸熏牛肉、炸卷心菜、炸辣椒、一团辣椒酱、泡菜和洋葱（如果你想要的话）制成的油腻面包，裹在玉米煎饼里，也就是说，这是受中国食物、犹太食物和洛杉矶辣椒传统影响的食物，裹在墨西哥风格的玉米煎饼里，由日本人为几乎全是美国黑人的客户烹制。
This is the Magic Carpet Restaurant, which is a black kosher Yemenite restaurant. Mmm. Smell that mint tea. That just smells great. Magic Carpet was sort of on the end of my year on Pico. I had eaten in perhaps 150 restaurants. But at some point during the year, I started relaxing the rules a little bit. I started passing by the mango carts. I started becoming less interested in the places that serve chili burgers that looked exactly like the place that served chili burgers a block away. And after a while, all pupusas started to look alike to me.
这是魔毯餐馆（Magic Carpet Restaurant），这是一家黑人洁食也门餐馆。嗯。闻闻那薄荷茶。那闻起来真是太棒了。魔毯餐馆大概是在我在皮科的一年即将结束时出现的。我可能已经在150家餐馆吃过了。但在那一年的某个时候，我开始放松规则了。我开始经过芒果推车。我开始对那些供应辣椒汉堡的地方不太感兴趣了，那些地方看起来和街区那头供应辣椒汉堡的地方一模一样。过了一会儿，所有的普普萨饼（pupusas）在我看来都一样了。
During the course of this year, I'd gotten the results of the first Foreign Service exam. I did pretty well. And on the second Foreign Service exam, I did better than I did on the first part. I'd been through my FBI search and had been fingerprinted and had been checked out by government physicians. I was ready to go. I was waiting for a posting somewhere. And it occurred to me that what I was looking for in the foreign service, that the sort of adventures I was hoping to have, that the sort of people I was hoping to meet, I was already having right there in my own hometown.
在这一年里，我收到了第一次外交服务考试的结果。我考得相当不错。在第二次外交服务考试中，我比第一部分考得更好。我通过了FBI审查，留下了指纹，并由政府医生检查过。我准备好了。我在等待某个地方的任命。我意识到，我在外交服务中寻找的东西，我希望拥有的那种冒险，我希望遇见的那种人，我已经在自己的家乡拥有了。
Jonathan Gold is now the restaurant critic for the LA Weekly and for Los Angeles Magazine . His food column "Counter Intelligence" was in the Los Angeles Times for eight years. His mission-- to help readers everywhere be less afraid of their neighbors using the medium of food.
乔纳森·戈尔德现在是《洛杉矶周刊》和《洛杉矶杂志》的餐厅评论家。他的美食专栏“反情报”在《洛杉矶时报》刊登了八年。他的使命——通过食物这种媒介，帮助各地的读者减少对邻居的恐惧。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Davenport. The deep voice behind the electronic nose frequently asked questions was Mr. Paul Friedman, Chicago voiceover man who also happens to be the official voice of the Chicago Cubs.
好的，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普戴克和我本人制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）协作，高级编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough），特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。来自劳拉·道格特（Laura Doggett）和[未听清]达文波特的制作帮助。电子鼻常见问题解答背后的深沉声音是保罗·弗里德曼（Paul Friedman）先生，他是芝加哥的配音员，也恰好是芝加哥小熊队的官方声音。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
If you want to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] , where you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Don't forget the special maps you'll find on the site this week. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who does the site for us for free. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是[email protected]，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。别忘了本周你在网站上会找到的特别地图。感谢为我们免费制作网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责。
Does management oversight require the electronic nose?
管理监督需要电子鼻吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
Does Torey Malatia have the electronic nose?
托里·马拉蒂亚有电子鼻吗？
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。